Facebook says it's cracking down on a
coordinated campaign designed to
interfere with the upcoming midterm
elections Facebook removed 32 pages and
apparently fake accounts that stoked
emotions over divisive issues more than
290 thousand accounts followed at least
one of the pages Facebook says it does
not have firm evidence of who's behind
the effort but it found similarities and
connections to a Russian firm accused of
meddling in the 2016 election CBS News
national security contributor Michael
Morell is with us from Washington he was
acting director and deputy director of
the CIA Mike good morning good morning
Nora Facebook has been reluctant to say
it is the Russians but do you feel
confident there behind this effort Nora
I have no doubt that the Russians are
behind the effort I think Facebook
doesn't want to be the organization that
does the attribution I think Facebook
rightfully believes that the government
should do that but the similarities in
patterns here and some of the techniques
the fact that one of the administrators
in these new accounts was an
administrator on the 2016 accounts I
think is is all the evidence we need to
say it's the Russian so very confident
in that judgment a number of digital
fingerprints there you know we heard the
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates say that the warning lights are
blinking red in terms of our cyber
system is is under attack is under
attack what does this mean for us so
cyber is one of those most significant
threats facing the United States both
people getting in networks to steal
information to possibly do damage to
information and to use those networks to
spread misinformation and political
influence I think director Coates was
talking about all of those things
Kristin Nielsen the Secretary of
Homeland Security said in a speech a
couple days ago that this is the
greatest threat that our country is
facing at the moment like facebook said
that that these these attacks are
getting more sophisticated than they
were in 2016 what's changing
it's clear to me Anthony that the
Russians learned from what they did in
2016 how they were discovered in 2016
and have taken steps to avoid discovery
that's why it took Facebook some time
here to find these accounts
so changing the internet protocols to
make it look like they're not coming
from Russia changing the way that they
paid for some of these ads in 2016 they
used rubles now they're using other
currencies so the Russians are going to
greater efforts to hide what they're
doing Mike the Facebook is policing
itself how is the US government doing
are we ready for this so Alex I don't
think we're doing enough particularly on
the deterrence side we have not deterred
lad Amir Putin what's absolutely clear
is that he continues to interfere in our
democracy and he is doing it without
without cost I think we need to the
Senate needs to the president needs to
significantly enhance the sanctions and
raise the pain on Putin so that he
thinks twice about what he's doing it's
also absolutely clear Alex that he has
lied to the president of United States
on multiple occasions and I think we
need to we need to understand that and
and make policy based on that rather
than what he says
Mike morale Thanks